Buenas tardes hemos escuchado los
argumentos tanto del gobierno central en
Londres como del gobierno regional
escocés que insiste en la importancia de
que la Corte Suprema emita un concepto
un fallo sobre si el parlamento escocés
es Hollywood tiene la posibilidad la
potestad constitucional de convocar un
segundo referendo de Independencia se ha
centrado en decir que esta es una
decisión muy importante Pública para la
gente en Escocia y en general en el
Reino Unido sin embargo el presidente de
la Corte Suprema ha dicho que estas
audiencias convocadas para estos dos
días son apenas la punta del iceberg de
toda la argumentación que tiene que
estudiarse después vendrán 8000
documentos y posteriormente se dará el
fallo que puede ser Incluso en meses
sobre si el gobierno regional escocés
tiene la potestad constitucional de no
pedir autorización a Londres para
realizar en este segundo referéndum de
Independencia hablamos de este segundo
referendo y le quiero preguntar de las
probabilidades de que esto suceda
en este momento no hay ninguna
probabilidad ni jurídica ni política las
relaciones entre Nicolás Torres la
primera ministra ministra principal
escocesa y la primera
ministras están en uno de sus peores
momentos Así que políticamente aunque
los nacionalistas escoceses tienen el
mandato y tienen mayorías en el
parlamento escocés en este momento esa
posibilidad no existe el gobierno
central en Londres dice que el referendo
ya se hizo fue en el 2014 pero ya no
habría una segunda oportunidad pero los
escoceses dicen que todo ha cambiado
porque el Reino Unido salió de la Unión
Europea y de una u otra manera se
sienten mucho más
europeos que británicos sin embargo
Nicolás Torres tiene la certeza y confía
dice en que puede entonces el alto
tribunal darle la razón y no tener que
pedir permiso ni autorización a Londres
para seguir con su camino de realizar un
segundo referendo tanto así ya fijó la
posible fecha del 19 de octubre 2023
para ese segundo referendo de
Independencia pero como les digo en este
momento esa posibilidad jurídica no
existe